dude literally i went to an all-boy
catholic high school in queens new york
shout out to archbishop malloy we were
all different races
even religions there were jewish and
muslim kids in a catholic school
whatever but they were boobs hoops
absolutely
yeah seriously and so and so below i
wouldn't accept them for any other
things
for some reason they were good at
basketball
yeah so it was all like this and dude
everybody nobody we would all everybody
was racist everybody said racist stuff
and did gay [ __ ] nobody's all boys
that's the thing it's like the military
almost like yes once you're around you
like you speak to guys that you have any
friends that are in the military well
yeah like the firemen too yeah yeah
everybody says the worst [ __ ] to each
other because there's nobody around to
really kind of judge i think when
they're like that when they're women
around uh we have to present ourselves a
little bit better because we're like
yeah yeah you got to make sure you want
to spend the rest of your life with me
right all right yeah that's true or
maybe you've got a friend that i'm going
to spend the rest of my life like we got
to start acting a little bit more
appropriate but when it's just like a
little bit of a boys club yeah it's a
little dangerous oh dude but it's
beautiful it's beautiful but that needs
to be there like when in my high school
dude everybody did said racist things
all different races and everybody did
gay [ __ ] but nobody is gay and nobody's
racist then i know mark says that like
uh what was it it was a boy school you
want to send your kids to or is it well
yeah why is that i mean it's just a
great energy i went to a boys school i
was in france and it was just like no
one was trying to put on for the girls
no one was trying to like show off
there's a bunch of guys doing dude stuff
and you could like focus or you could
like like tune in with the guys and just
[ __ ] around but i realized like
everything i do in my life like to try
to like look good and feel good is just
for other guys yeah because girls i'm
super impressed by like memphis
grizzlies or vancouver
yeah no dude no
literally this is just i it was laundry
day because my you know i got a newborn
baby she throws up on everything yeah
and this is the only thing i because i
put on like the dad 20 pounds it's the
only thing that doesn't hug my ass
because it's every shirt i have it fits
in the front and then the back it just
gets tight on my ass so i needed
something loose in the back and this
just this flips down like like a
colonial coat you know what just like
goes down where you can't see my ass
that is interesting though like i wonder
if you don't have extended time around
just dudes do you ever really learn how
to socialize with them
what do you mean like uh like
socializing with men is different you
know like we don't want you to pretend
like we would rather the person that
says a little bit more [ __ ] up [ __ ]
right then we know who they are than the
person who's like being super
professional polite and i think you
learn that by playing sports sure you
know just being around these
environments where it's only dudes and
they're saying wild [ __ ] you get to kind
of be yourself
but like once you put a girl in the mix
it does change the dynamic
yeah i worked at a restaurant once and
they hired a woman like uh for the
kitchen because the kitchen staff was
wildin they were just acting too crazy
there was a bunch of dudes back there
right
and um i was like i was like i got a
curiosity like why did you hire uh hire
this to this woman to work back there as
well and um the boss was like uh you'll
see they'll just start dressing a little
bit better and like not saying as much
[ __ ] and the food will come out in time
and like within two days i believe it
everything completely changed can i
believe it because everybody in the
kitchen is trying to get [ __ ] they're
like making the best version of the
pasta and making the best version pizza
etc so i'm just like maybe you need that
like as a dude maybe you need that i
believe that everybody and everything
you're motivated by sex so once
sometimes sex you get to kind of find
out who you really are but i don't think
you can ever remove sex that's the thing
but around just dudes you can i don't
know i still think that there's some
type of no because i think there's some
type of primal thing happening in our
brains where we still want to be the
dominant one just in case a woman comes
in yeah but that's more important when
the woman's there like when it's just
the homies
everybody's fine to like bust balls etc
but you make fun of me in front of the
girl i'm trying to [ __ ] now it's
different right you know what i mean if
it's just the four of us here we're
making fun of each other who gives a
[ __ ] but like if you're trying to
impress a chick and then we just start
railing on you alex it's like yo what's
what's going on here yeah you have to uh
establish who's alpha so when the chick
comes around it's like you can't just
automatically just start acting but
y'all don't let your friend be alpha in
front of the girl
like when when my boy is trying no but
it's not a girl
he's with a girl and you're still like
listen i need you to know who alpha is
yeah but what if it's not just all
friends what is just a group of guys
like at school no i'm just talking about
them like if it's all boys school you
still got to know who's who at the all
boys school i guess i don't know i think
that's a beautiful thing about sports
too is like sports just establishes it's
like everybody knows who's nice at
basketball everybody knows who's funny
in class everybody knows who's good at
talking to the girls and then you have
like these different versions of these
different hierarchies but
excuse me but then you have like you
have a girl into this situation it gets
a little um yeah everybody starts you
know
everybody starts fronting a little bit
i mean yeah i wonder if girls feel that
like girls got to feel that there's got
to be girls listening to this podcast
right now and they're like yeah 100 i
feel guys completely change in their
nature sure dude like you ever like be
talking to your boys and like a girl
will walk down the street and everybody
just stops the conversation of course
she can't even like continue a
conversation yeah yeah so of course that
energy is going to shift if a girl's in
a room
my girl now because i was just lit i
mean we were literally fighting every
time we went out in public because i
would just be looking at women that she
just doesn't care now she's just like if
she sees a girl that she's identifying
as hot she just allows me to just like
look at her for a few seconds then come
back to the conversation and it's
literally saved our relationship because
she's just out of your she's just
allowed me to do it she's just like just
take a peek look obviously you can't go
near her or anything like that but just
go ahead yeah and and then i'll she'll
allow me to break concentration because
i used to just you know just try to you
know lie and be like i wasn't looking at
her i was looking at the sign and but it
was just you know asses you know but but
um you know she's so i think like the
more your girl like just understands
what this all is like you know the male
brain the better it's going to be for
you yeah you know but i will say you
know with with sports sports is one of
those things like i'm i want to push
both my kids to do that because sports
is like that like it transcends
everything like i feel like i was
accepted in every community because i
could play basketball yeah like i was
just i have so many friends from out
like and it's like if you can't play
sports like my stepson doesn't doesn't
play sports and i'm trying to push him
into it because i'm like dude you got to
understand like if you're just if you're
good at this you don't know how many
doors open feel like i only at points in
my life dude you have to see what i used
to look like like like
full mushroom haircut like a number six
at supercuts [ __ ] doof you know like
doof doof doof but i had a nice jump
shot yeah so i would go on dates with
girls that were way out of my league
because i could play a ball yeah so you
know i mean fellas you're charismatic
man no
no you will shoot i take swings
bro i remember we were at some event and
rita ora was there yeah dude yeah
chrissy went after him
and you know what i did i took a shot
because i figured every other guy in
here is going to ask for you know to
have the same line so i asked for her
[ __ ] email and i started emailing her
and that was a mistake i know you did
that yeah
yeah yeah well that was a mistake yeah
yeah because she emailed me back she
emailed me back why why are we emailing
i forgot what i said some dumb [ __ ] but
yeah i took that big swing she thought i
was a a baseball player yeah that's what
she said she said because you were doing
a baseball show yeah she was like are
you a baseball player and i was like
yeah yeah and then she realized quickly
that i wasn't but i remember yeah i
remember the rita ora thing [ __ ] i took
a big i take so many stuff you'll take
swings you don't care because the thing
is with me is i realize that like it's
just moment like our life is just
moments you're not worried about the
rejection at all no dude yeah no reject
me but that's the thing
but that's the thing with sports is i've
learned how to lose i learn you learn
how to lose from an early age so i can
do yeah like i don't get hung up on
anything like the male ego like any time
i see a guy getting insecure about
you know a girl leaving him or cheating
on me i'm like shut up dude you're such
a little weak [ __ ] yeah oh you're a
[ __ ] weenie just shut up so what she
cheated on you stink go out and talk to
the next girl yeah i don't care